jacques benillouche journalistes aux
israéliens bonsoir jacques benillouche
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt
france est ce que la crise est terminée
en israël le fait qu'il y ait enfin un
gouvernement
c'est une bonne nouvelle la crise est
terminée mais les problèmes vous
commencez par ce que il ya beaucoup de
différences dans les approches
politiques des deux gouverneurs des deux
gouvernements
alors il y a d'abord le problème le plus
important qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
c'est le problème de la lectio vous avez
trois plans d'alexion différentes selon
la personne
nous avons le plan d'injection de train
le plan d'injection de gans et le plan
d'alexion de neda liens que ce sont
trois plans différents le plus favorable
je dirais à la droite nationaliste
en israël c'est le plan preuve on sent
qu'il a voulu donner satisfaction à
toute la frange de l'irena frange je
nationalise du pays et aussi les
évangélistes chrétiens qui sont ces ses
électeurs alors le plan entre qu'est-ce
qu'elle différentiel qu'il plantera qui
veut annexer 130 colonies 130
implantations à travers l'ensemble du
pays l'ensemble la cisjordanie et il
veut annexer une l'angle une angle 1 et
angles de terre entre le lac de
tibériade et la mer morte
ça c'est le plan qui est prévu par
grands patrons en revanche le plan gans
et beaucoup plus timide
d'ailleurs il est un peu flou pendant
les élections il n'a pas voulu tellement
se prononcer il prévoit lui entre limay
de maths de renforcer la sécurité
nationale et d'oeuvrer à la paix et
oeuvrer à la paix c'est tellement
général qu' on ne sait pas exactement ce
qu'il veut faire
il ne prononce pas le mot d'alexion il
précise il prévoit le rattachement
d'implantation proche de jérusalem comme
maalé adoumim qui touche qui est à 10 km
pratiquement de jérusalem est comme le
qu'on l'appelle gauche ex young et le
sud de jérusalem est qui sont des
implantations qui touche aussi jérusalem
alors lui il est prêt à je dirais
inclure ces implantations mais ne parle
pas du tout d'annexion et c'est là où
elle va être le problème c'est que il va
falloir trancher
nous sommes assure que natanyahou
veuille vraiment eu passé le sauter le
pas il sait qu'il a des problèmes il
sait qu'il a des problèmes d'abord dans
son parti c'est pas le moment de
réveiller un petit peu sur ces problèmes
et il est à l'heure actuelle soumis à la
pression de train trump veut que tout
ceci se décide avant l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'il a besoin des
voix juives aux états unis il a besoin
des voix comme je le disais évangélistes
or il est en difficulté
d'abord à cause de la crise du corona
qui l'a qui la complète qui a tué
l'économie américaine et surtout parce
que joe biden le dépasse maintenant sur
le plan de les sondages donc aujourd'hui
c'est 30 qui pousse natanyahou à sauter
le pas or il faut savoir que l'armée et
c'est elle qui peut organiser ces
élections entre guillemets est bien
l'armé est totalement contre cette
annexion il ya eu récemment 220 généraux
qui ont publié un document disant qu'ils
sont contre l'annexion
ils ne sont pas prêts à accepter
l'annexion et ils sont pas prêts non
plus à accepter une décote décisions
unilatérales comme elle avait eu lieu à
gaza donc date and yahoo c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il a un genou à terre
il a accepté il a accepté contre sa
volonté de collaborer avec gand il a une
opposition interne au sein de son parti
puisqu'il a d'ailleurs été forcé
d'éliminer tous les dirigeants
historiques d'une écoute donc on sent
qu'il n'est pas prêt aujourd'hui à créer
un incident a créé un problème avec
cette annexion il y avoue recevons ce
pardon pardonnez moi même si les
la haye les affaires de corruption pour
benyamin nétanyahou est ce que la crise
est passée par là et a effacé aussi ses
problèmes en sortir renforcé de cette
crise sanitaire
il ya la crise sanitaire vous voulez
parler du grenat ça c'est sûr il a été
il avait bien gagné l'opération il a
bien mené l'opération et nous avons été
nous sommes parmi les pays qui avons le
moins de mort de 148 exactement ce qui
est négligeable par rapport à notre pays
mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
gouvernement natanyahou passe en
jugement bientôt devant ces tribunaux
c'est dans quelques jours et donc il
n'est pas utile et pas il a d'autres
chats à fouetter que ces annexions et il
n'est pas soumis
il est soumis comme tout citoyen au juge
et il n'y a pas d'idée d'immunité
parlementaire dont il a trop de problème
à l'heure actuelle pour créer un
incident vous savez 60% de la population
n'est pas d'accord
l'annexion parce que l'annexion ça veut
dire avoir des populations arabes qui
s'intègre dans vos pays qui s'intègre à
israël lui enlevant tous totalement son
identité juive
donc c'est pour ça que je dirais que
cette année à un genou à terre il ya eu
trois élections qui l'ont mis en
difficulté et c'est pour ça qu'au sein
de son parti
les médecins sont partis c'est un petit
peu la curée ils veulent commencer
éventuellement à l'éliminer de la
direction du parti et c'est pour ça
qu'il a été contraint de ne pas prendre
certains opposants dans son gouvernement
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que le
problème de l'annexion n'est pas un
problème fondamental nous abordons une
crise comme tous les pays une crise
économique importante
le pays israël est établi qu'il n'avait
pas chômage
eh bien nous avons un très grand saut
maja millions de chômeurs pour une
population de 8 millions c'est énorme
nous avons des entreprises qui déposent
le bilan
elles sont pas aidées par l'état à
l'état ne fait rien pour les pme temps
de circuler dans goûter
centres commerciaux je les fais ce matin
il ya des 100 aride et magasins qui ont
fermé des boutiques de fringues des
restaurations qui des récents qui faire
donc je pense que c'est pour ça que je
me je voudrais dire que question de deux
d'injection passe par dessus la tête
excusez-moi liquéfie longtemps et
pourtant ça a été une des déclarations
de benyamin nétanyahou assez forte
aujourd'hui en absolument il a voulu
montrer que ils avaient besoin
il faut savoir qu'il avait besoin du
vote vous savez qu'il y avait un doute
sur le vote de certains de certains de
ceux de membres du likoud qui était prêt
à ne pas voter la confiance
or effectivement on à 72 une majorité de
72 perdre débuté mais il suffit que onze
députés ne votent pas ou se portent pas
ou quittent la salle
et pour que tous les recours non n'est
pas vraiment donc il n'était pas
question aujourd'hui de créer l'incident
avec son parti mais à la longue on est
sûr aujourd'hui que le 1er juillet n'est
pas une date définitive on a dit que la
partie du 1er juillet il allait faire
l'annexion à mon avis ce n'est pas une
date qui est fermé
ce n'est pas une date qui est de
l'équipe définitive ça va traîner vous
savez cette histoire de cette histoire
l'annexion on l'a connu en soixante sept
avec le fameux plan allon un général qui
avait gagné la guerre de 67 qui avait
proposé ce plan à l'homme qui est
pratiquement le plan très légèrement
modifié donc si on 67
c'est quelque chose qui traîne c'est
quelque chose qu'il traîne depuis 67
sans aucune des décisions c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'on va se lancer dans des
décisions alors que nous avons des
problèmes plus importants beaucoup plus
important sur le plan sécuritaire vous
savez l'aviron voilà merci beaucoup
jacques benillouche pour votre analyse
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france